- Un matin difficile
à Saint-Adolphe-d'Howard :
arbres déracinés, routes
bloquées, toits arrachés.
Pierre Beller ne reconnaît pas
le quartier qu'il aime tant.
PIERRE BELLER,
de Saint-Adolphe-d'Howard
- C'est t d'un coup.
On était en train de souper.
Il y avait eu des grêlons avant,
les grêlons grossissaient,
tout était calme, puis un moment
donné, les arbres se sont mis
quasiment à se coucher à terre.
- Son voisin est resté marqué
par le bruit.
JACQUES JUNEAU,
de Saint-Adolphe-d'Howard
- Les arbres se sont mis à
craquer, à tomber de tout côté.
C'était... c'était assez
incroyable. Moi, j'avais
jamais vu ça.
- Une tornade serait à l'origine
de ces dégâts selon
Environnement Canada.
Les pompiers font le tour
du quartier pour dégager
les débris de la route.
Sur les lignes électriques,
les dommages sont importants.
Des centaines de personnes
ont perdu le courant.
ALAIN PAQUETTE,
porte-parole d'Hydro-Québec
- Difficile pour nos équipes
d'accéder au réseau compte tenu
des dommages. C'est carrément
des portions du réseau
qui sont à reconstruire.
- Pierrepassé la nuit
à l'hôpital. Sa femme a souffert
d'un stress post-traumatique.
Mais dans la région,
aucune blessure grave
n'a été rapportée.
- Les dégâts, c'est pas
important, ça. On est en vie,
qui compte.
- Contrairement à sa voiture,
la maison n'a pas été touchée.
Il appelle ses ass
pour faire évaluer les dégâts
le plus vite possible.
- Saint-Adolphe-d'Howard n'estp.
Fin mai, des orages violents
avaient fait des ravages
et d'autres graves pannes de
courant dans les L.
- Cette année, disons qu'on
commence à en avoir notre lot.l.
- Pierre Beller ne veut plus
courir de risque. Il compte
enlever encore plus d'arbres
de son terrain pour protéger
sa maison et sa paix d'esprit.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-Canada,
Saint-Adolphe-d'H